you
[Music]
it's our great pleasure today to have
Eric true here Eric is a PhD candidate
from University of Toronto advised by
Rene Miele his research focuses on data
discovery and similarity search he's a
recipient of the Bell graduate
scholarship and also a vldb best demo
would without further ado Marek thank
you yeah yeah okay so it's nice to be
here and my talk is on the search for
join about tables in data lakes so
before I begin I want to talk a little
bit about my back on so I would burn a
trace in China Council and it was a
technology hub and home to Alibaba and
some other tech companies unfortunately
I don't know anything about programming
on here I started my undergrad at
University of Toronto sorry I liked it
so much that I decided to a PhD in
programming and I had no regret so some
of you might think I look familiar
because I did I was fetching more people
because I did an internship in 2016 at a
dms coop and I had a great pleasure to
work with you and Sergey so during the
internship we even won the first place
in DMS Cup yes so that was a team effort
and let's go back to the main topic so I
would like to start with the traditional
enterprise data analytic workflow so in
this workflow the data scientist has to
work with a very heavy IT process to get
data now this process is so inflexible
that it prevents the data scientists
from iterating with new changes or
trying out new ideas so to make the life
better for them a new concept came along
called data Lake so this little a
concept atom case or the data scientist
to work directly with the raw data and
bypass the IT now
this way the data scientists would enjoy
much greater flexibility and be very
happy but it is a reality or a fantasy
we can take look at a two examples so in
the first example the data scientist has
a table on companies and he wants to
find out more information about those
companies we can translate this question
into a query for tables that could be
joined with the existing table but but
the existing solution for data like such
as the data table doesn't really support
keyword search or it only supports
keyword search and category browsing so
it cannot really handle the query in a
different example let's say the data
scientists already find a table that
could be joined together but the problem
is this table has different formats on
the join columns so he could spend say
15 minutes writing a script to make the
format consistent before you apply the
join but imagine that you have your 20
with many new data sets and you want to
iterate it with new changes this ad-hoc
script writing could potentially eat up
a tremendous amount of a work time right
so what happened is instead of bypassing
the IT department the data scientists in
fact we became the IT department alright
so it's not necessary about them because
having flexibility is great but on the
other hand now the job has become much
more demanding and carries more
responsibilities so my the goal of my
research is to make this job much easier
let's summarize my contributions
I developed algorithm for search engine
about tables in data Lake and as well as
automatically join them these algorithms
will make data sizes more powerful so in
this talk I want to focus on
about tables search so how do we define
this problem we let the user would input
a table we call query table and we'll
specify a column we call it a query
column and from a data link of tables we
try to find tables that can be joined
with my query table on a query column so
how do we define the relevance of those
table well how do we define Joan ability
so we define Joan ability is the
fraction of distinct values in the query
column that could be covered by the
joint okay so why do we care about
searching for tunable tables I'm going
to give you to motivate motivating
examples to show why so in the first
example from this is from Canadian Open
Data the query table is on the homicide
count by firearms in Canada so you can
see this definitely not the US data
[Laughter]
right so if we want to understand what
is correlated with this trend we could
search for tables that can be joined on
the time column now looking from the
data Lake we find a new table on the
police officers in Canada so we put this
two trend together we discover some very
interesting correlations and from this
one we can perhaps even draw some
unexpected conclusions in a different
example the query table is on the
pollution of various industrial
facilities in Canada and we want to
predict the pollution amount now if we
search for jollyball tables on the
postal code column we find a new table
on the political campaign contributions
so the contributors postal code can be
joined with the postcode of the
industrial facilities so by joining
these two tables together we introduce
potentially useful features for predict
for the partition task
okay so if joinable table is so a
stowable table search is so useful how
can we integrate it into an application
right I'm going to show you a
demonstration of this a system that we
built for John about tables search and
you can see how user can interactively
combine tables from a data like two to
create a table for the analysis right so
in this demo the user will start with a
query table so we find the query table
using keyword search so we look for in
search of what data so answer is similar
to with the NSF in in the US and by
searching for a circle award we find the
application the partners in those
immigrants application so these are the
partners or companies that applies for a
circle words and by searching on ID
columns we find the table about the
awards themselves now we can join these
two tables together now we associate the
company that applies for the awards and
the awards themself so from the award
table we find an interesting attribute
the amount of money involved in this
research award or grant and what we're
doing now is we're adding a sequel query
to project our columns that we are
interested in
I will select the column about the
company name and we also take the sum of
the research grant that they received
from a sook now we have a new table
after doing the projection it summarizes
how much money each company received
from in sook we can continue out with
searching for journal tables and we find
more tables that could be joined with a
company name column so in this one we
find a table on a political campaign
contributions now we join these two
tables together we links every single
contribution with the contributor which
are the companies in my previous table
so in this contribution table we have
the amount of money involved in each
contribution as well as the political
party of the candidate who's receiving
the contribution so we're going to run
another sequel query to get the
attributes that we are interested in so
we select the company name the amount of
money they received from a stock reward
and the political party that those
company contributes to and we are
summing the amount of donation the total
amount of monetary donation or
contribution they make to each political
party as you can see the user are kind
of combining various table together
using joinable table search to create a
new table that allowed them to run their
analysis so in the end we get a table
that correlates the amount of money they
receive from a search and how much money
they donate to
parties I found this table we can make
some interesting discoveries so that was
the end of the demo hope you enjoyed it
and so I want to give you an overview of
the system behind the demonstration
right so we first process this sets from
columns in the data Lakes so from those
sets we index them in a search index and
then the user will input a table we use
the same process to extract the query
set and then we create the search index
then the searching - would give us a
list of columns and table IDs that could
be joined with the query table and that
from which we render the user interface
so that's generally how the demo works
so this demo one the best demo a word
that we ought to be 2017 the people are
very excited about it and the secret
sauce that makes the search so
interactive is the search index so I
developed two search indexes the first
one is our sage and sambal which publish
at we ought to be 2016 and another one
is called Josie is published at the OTB
oh sorry
stickball 2019 and has a US patent
pending so go ahead questions we're
talking about hundreds of thousands of
tables so typically an open data portal
would have quite number of tables in
terms of CSV files or and they'll be the
largest tables that you have the larger
table that we have actually were going
to talk about later is about 222 million
rows and then in terms of the joint
ability is your definition in join yes
so the demo that you saw was used in our
siege and sambal and I want to start
with this one first so when we talk
about indexing the data like what are
the challenges so a data layer can have
a lots of large very big tables as we
talk about the poi and so that leads to
the sets being very large so the largest
set is 22 million different values
another honor than the dimension data
lei can have hundreds of thousands of
tables so we talked about a lot of sets
right so how do we deal with this type
of scale we use an approach called D
this sketch
so the data sketch you can think of it
as simply fixed size summaries of sets
and they have very interesting property
that gives you probabilities to
guarantee and estimating certain certain
stuff like similarities and they are
very cheap to build you just need to
scan the table once so out of many
different data sketches we picked Ming
hash for our joinable table search
problem so I want to give you a quick
review of how many hash works so Ming
has is essentially a list of hash values
generated by a list of random hash
functions for each hash functions we
scan across all the values in this set
and we keep the minimum hash value and
we do it for the second hash function
and so on until we have completed all
the hash functions so what are we gonna
do with this mean hash signatures or
sketches it turns out that the minimum
hashed value has a very interesting
mathematical property so the probability
of two minimum hash value be equal is
actually the same the jakers similarity
of the sets so how can we use this
property for joining all table search we
can use hash table
to find approximately durable columns
under Jayco similarly what am i what do
I mean by that
because when columns if they are
joinable they will have some nonzero
probability of hashing to the same key
but if they're not joinable they will
have zero probability of having to the
same key so we can simply return the
columns that get hash to the same value
as the critical so that's very simple we
can even further improve the accuracy by
using locality sensitive hashing index
so the locality has been rehashed in
instead of using a single hash value as
the key with combining the hashed value
into a composite key and keep them in a
hash table so this plot shows why our
search would improve the accuracy as you
can see the x-axis is the g-code
similarity of a candidate set and the
y-axis is the probability of retrieving
these candidates from the our search
index so there is a s-curve relationship
between the probability and a jig high
similarity without using our stage this
relationship will be linear so you can
see the difference so what our search
does is it allow us to optimize this our
s curve around given Jayco similarity
threshold so that we can minimize the
error probabilities essentially we want
to stretch the curve in a way that the
area correspond to the errors is the
smallest right so now we know how our
search works so before we move on to say
how about we just use our SH to search
for join about tables we need to think
about this problem a question whether J
curve similarity is a right measure for
joining about tables we can think about
this using a small example let's say we
have two pairs of sets
and they're intersecting size are the
same right
but the Jake our similarities are very
different the first one would be much
bigger than the second one the reason
for that is because the Jake are
similarity is intersecting size divided
by the union size and the second pair
has a much bigger unit size so it's not
fair because these two sets are supposed
to have the same relevance given our
definition of Joan ability so
alternatively we use a different
similarity measure call so instead of
dividing by the Union size we divide by
the size of the query okay so this is
consistent with our definition of Joan
ability now we call this measure
containment and we use that for our
relevance score so we're really trying
to do here now is how do we fix
Nanaji rsh so that you can work with
containment search the result of this is
our stage ensemble which is a included
in a Python Public Library I called it a
sketch so that this library has been
used by a lot of people it's widely
popular
so from github you can see who uses your
library as a dependency so I found that
Google MIT and Stanford they all use
this one so it has kind of big impact
and generated over 760 stars on github
so it was very popular so before I talk
about how me our searching sample works
I want to give you some kind of
intuition okay so this formula applying
inclusion exclusion principle you can
map a containment to a j-card
all right so what this gives us is a
translation formula so you can translate
a containment threshold into a Jake
whole similarities vessel how do we use
this
what the user will say okay I want
containment ratio to be t-star use the
translation formula you get a Jake odds
ratio as
star and as you remember from before we
can use that I start to tune the Alice H
index to minimize the error we do it
back to that right yeah it's all good
can we just be done with it there's a
very big problem with this translation
formula can you spot what is the problem
so the problem with that is that the X
mod is not a constant so X is the size
of the set and there of course more than
one status right in the index so instead
of using this one we can use alternative
approximation so instead of using the
size of every single set we use the
maximum size of all the sets so that
will give us a constant right now this
is the consequence of using this
approximation translation formula the
accesses here is the containment
threshold and the y-axis here is a
translated Jake are similarly Thresher
and the top curve the orange curve is
the correct translation function well
the bottom curve is the approximate
translation function so you can see the
gap in between what the area is would be
the false positives to give you a quick
example let's say my containment ratio
is 0.6 and the correct translation
should tell me the Jacob movie file to
be DuPont boy but in the end what's
actually being used is 0.2 so imagine
you optimize the our search index on 0.2
you will get in between the 0.2 of them
for the post positive candidates right
so you can say okay you know false
positive we can always post process
right we can verify their exact
continents by computing them exactly
yeah it's easy but the sap can be very
large so the pros processing could be
very expensive right
now I can show you using the small
example here let's say I have an index
and it has some different step sizes in
this index and there are some small sets
and there's some large set and the
maximum set size of 100 so for a set
with side three the first positive area
is really large
wait that's not good it means that we're
gonna get a lot of sets in our post
positioning step so how can you pick
that a simple trick is just to you know
have separate indexes one for the small
sets going for the large sets so for the
small sets the upper bound is much much
smaller and now is 4 so the area for the
postpositive is much smaller it's same
for the large set as well so using this
kind of separate indexes with the
approach of using separate indexes it
essentially inspires us to develop a new
solution for reducing the false positive
instead of using put posts yes because
it's actually by the nature of a
translation formula because if you go
back to the translation formula it uses
u divided by the query size and if the
query sizes is much smaller than the the
upper bound then the line will close to
a linear curve but it's not just still a
little bit curved because the vadi
nominator is now much bigger - old let's
say 0.7 0.8 right what happens
like if you were to go back to the night
set case yeah don't you want oh so what
they're saying that point eight you need
to do
jacquard of 0.1 but not too many Falls
for it 0.1 but not too many power but
yes so the 0.1 because settimeout much
bigger competitive query yeah as we
remember from before I just want to
insert a little bit notes the the jaicro
similarity is heavily influenced by the
union sites right so if the Union size
is bigger because of a success is large
then you need to have smaller Jake
Hollis restaurant for a large container
yeah but so our approach is so our
approach instead of using a single Alice
H index we want to build separate our
situation Dex's partitions of this sets
so how do we create these partitions we
sort all set by their sizes and we
create disjoint partitions with
increasing set sizes so what happened is
the first partition will have smaller
set sizes than the second partition the
second position will have small set
aside and a third partition is so on
right so the benefit of doing the
partitioning is that it reduces the
false positive rate
add almost an inverted quadratic of the
differences in maximum sizes so now you
may ask the question if the partitioning
is so powerful can we simply create
infinite number of partitions the answer
is of course it's not very verbal
because the query cost will be growing
linearly with the number of partitions
so in order to optimize the partitions
we would derive a formula to compute the
upper bound of number of false positive
coming from is your partition given the
size interval so using this formula we
can try to solve a small example let's
say I have 100 sets
and with uniform distribution of sizes
from 1 to 100 now I want to create two
partitions so we want to find but
looking for the bat location of the
boundary we want to find the best
boundary that give us the smallest
number of false positives and the result
is shown in this plot so the axis is is
the partition boundary the middle line
here and the y axis is the number of
false positive upper bound so by sliding
it over this possible values we find
that the up key mode to partition
boundary is around 50 so now we know how
to solve the two optimal to partition
case for a uniform distribution right
but the problem is the real data
distribution is not always uniform in a
case of open data is actually close to
the p.m. so how we're going to do about
that
so we can kind of model this problem as
an integer programming problem the
variables are the publishing boundaries
so given n partitions you have n minus 1
different variables and the objective is
to minimize the total false positive
from all the partitions so integer
program is np-hard but for this
particular problem we can actually solve
it using dynamic programming and the
complexity of dynamic programming is big
o of N squared with n big n is the size
so the total number of different sizes
set sizes I multiplied by the number of
partitions so the complexity same it's
really bad it's bigger than squares but
in reality in practice this is actually
really manageable it's very interesting
you can think of it as comparing the
differences between how much money Jeff
Bezos have and how much money I have
that's gonna be in hundreds of billions
of dollars right at least before the
divorce so now you compare that number
with the number of bank accounts in the
US the
is going to be smaller than the
differences so similarly in Dayton Lakes
we for open data we found this about
14,000 different sizes and for web table
we found about four thousand different
sizes so it's actually not that big and
using Python in a laptop we can actually
finish the optimization ten minutes so
that's well that's the dynamic program
so I want to summarize how our system
works the user would provide a query and
say I want a containment well shorty
stop now the indexing process uses
information to build the index the first
doing dynamic programming to optimize
the partition boundaries build our SH
index a soulish partition and the tune
the our search indexes using the con
translation formula and during the query
time is simply probe the hash tables and
optionally you can remove the post
partum but that would cost a lot less
than if you don't use our optimization
strategy so the paper also talks about
how to handle arbitraries query sites
and containment threshold so that user
doesn't have to be index everything
before you can run a new query so what's
the benefit of using our search for
example first of all we didn't mention
that you can actually paralyze your
query over multiple partitions but up to
the point where up to the number of
course you have on your machine of
course another benefit is a created
footprint is much very small because
we're using a Hodge data sketch and it's
very scalable so we tested on the whole
web table of 200 million sets
so that was our second sample next I'm
going to move on to Josie which is a
paper that's published in this year in
Sigma so some people may ask me okay so
for the same problem why do you have two
different algorithms to be care there
are different algorithms and different
problems so for our surgeon sample it is
an approximated index for threshold
based search but for Josie is an exact
algorithm but for top K so now what when
do we want to use top K weight the four
threads your search the user would have
to provide a continuous vessel so they
may not even know what is the
appropriate ratio to use sometime it
returns too many results sometimes we
return to little later on they may not
even understand what it means right now
the top Kate doesn't have this problem
you simply return a predefined K with us
and then that's why it is used by the
search engines because the user doesn't
actually care about how you rank the
results there's no knowledge of the
relevance measures required but the most
interesting bit is that we find for an
exact algorithm if Kempe our performance
our search and sample wizard which is an
approximate algorithm when the our
samples are using a decreasing special
hack to do top k so the idea was you
just reduce this ratio until you get K
results typically you get to carries out
and do the post-processing so when do we
use top K we want to use top K when the
user is not so sophisticated and the K
is small so this is actually very common
right now we can start to define what is
top K overlap search so we have a
different name for this joint ability
measures
record overlap it's actually equivalent
to the intersection sets and it is also
equivalent to the containment because
for any given query the queue the size
of the crew is fixed right so before I
start talking about Jodie I want to give
you a very quick review of inverted
index it may look very different from
the textbook so inverted index is used
by many exact algorithms also Josie is
using inverted index you can visualize
it as a very gigantic matrix so in this
matrix the rows are sets and the columns
are data values if you take a row you
will get the data values as contained in
the set right if you take a column you
get the sets that contain the data value
and we call this column a posting list
that's using the inverted index term
terminologies so let's say using
inverted index we want to find the top
one overlap weight and the first base
line we talked about is very simple it's
called posting lists Union what do you
do is just read all the posting lists
and count the appearance of each set and
take the one that has most appearances
it's very simple now if we look at how
much it cost
it reads seven values okay now the
second base line is called prefix
filtering some of them by some of you
might know this the idea is a little bit
involved so instead of reading all the
posts in this you read them one by one
you read the first post in list and read
all the set that you discover from the
post Ness after the point when there's
no more new cells can be the one the
best one you have so in this case we
found that x4 completely overlap to my
query so we say okay s4 is a winner we
stop so it costs 18 values
so in this case the post in this union
wins out prefix filtrate well if we
change sets we get a different results
in this case the previous filtering with
a lot less value than the post inlets
Union so why is there such differences
this is because both none of these
algorithms consider we cost now why do
we care about risk Austin because cost
is huge in data Lake as we remember from
before data Lake has very large sets a
lot of them also very long post illness
and a lot of them as well so the cost of
reading those posted us and says can be
not it cannot be neglected therefore a
very efficient algorithm that works for
data Lake must be able to reduce we
costs so how do we reduce because it's
actually very interesting if you read a
candidate set you can actually reduce
the work that you would have to do to
read the post and us so here's how it
goes let's say we read a post news and
we start reading x4 and we found that x4
has overlap of 4 with my query right now
what does the mean is for any new sets
that we haven't seen from the post list
that we haven't read the maximum overlap
can have can be at most 3 because they
can only show up at most three places v4
v5 and visa
they're never gonna make it to the top
one and we can stop we limited all the
post in it that's how if we read a
candidate set we reduce the work of a
reading post in this it works the other
way around as well if we let's say we
read through post in this and we
discover these candidate sets up there
act wise to add pre at boy so if we
assume that the current top one overlap
is for let's just say it's poor ok
what do we know from the posting list is
that X 1 X 2 and X we can have has has
only one value after V for the last
potion is that we read but what does it
mean it means that these candidates that
can have at most to overlap with my
career because they also has only one
overlap in the positives that we've seen
so we say well they can have almost two
overlaps we don't care about them so we
by reading their post in this without
reading the candidate set we get rid of
them get rid of the rip read costs
associate with those candidate sets so
it's actually what you can see is that
we can go both directions you can read
posting this to get rid of some
candidate sets or you can read candidate
set to get rid of some posionous so this
kind of choices inspire us to create
Josie so for Josie would define work is
the amount of cost or read costs
associated with with read the remaining
post lists and candidate sets and we
define progress as the reduction work as
you have seen before reading candidates
adds reduce work really impose a list
also reduce work but there's a cost
associated with each progress by reading
the cancer is that you would have to pay
the price of reading it the same for the
posting list
so the algorithm works as follows as
long as yours work remaining you
estimate the progress that's involved in
each direction and pick one that gives
you the best in that progress which is
defined as the progress - the price so
this seems simple but the magic actually
goes on into this algorithm is in this
line if we use a cost model to estimate
the progress for the presentation I
don't have lots of
time to cover this detail we can carry
up line or after the presentation but
the answer is in the title so we use
intersection estimation to build up this
cost model we evaluate Josie on two
benchmarks the open data and web tables
and we observe very good performance up
to five times over the baseline of the
exact algorithms I think the other
interesting bit is that it can get up to
two time performance over our search in
Samba when using the decreasing ratio
hack but the catch is it only worked
well for small query query actually it's
not that small the query under 5,000
different values and it's small case
okay under 20 but I think it's
reasonable because most of the time user
won't look beyond 10 so this plot shows
the performance comparison between Josie
and the baseline exact algorithms you
don't have to look further than this
line this is the k equal to 10 and this
is Josie and these are the exact
baseless so it just completely initial
it's the other approach and shows how
important it is to consider every cost
in data leaks okay so that concludes
oszi in addition to jolly-boat table
search I want to talk about other works
that I have done in the area of data
Lake so the one that worth mentioning is
Auto John it is a project that I did
during my internship at MSR actually I
think many of you were actually at the
presentation at the end of my internship
so the paper led to vldb 20:17 paper
thanks yeah yeah it was really good and
this algorithm what it does is
essentially automatically generates a
transformation function that can convert
the format's into a consistent format
for equal join so what is a highlight of
this algorithm so the highlight is that
unlike many existing approaches this
algorithm does not requires any user
inputs does not require you to provide
examples I also did other work in
searching tables indeed Olech so in this
work table Union search instead of
searching for joining both tables we
search for tables that can be stacked
together and align the columns you can
create a masterless of certain type of
records so beyond search we also look at
how do we organize tables into category
hierarchical category according to the
topic the idea is to help user to
minimize the number of hoops they would
need to do in order to arrive at the
table that are interested in so in terms
of future work there are many different
direction that we can go the first one I
want to talk about is the pre-processing
step so far we only considered equal
join on key sorry equal join on data
values we haven't really considered the
case of let's say multi sets but what if
your join ability definition is not the
dist own distinct values but on the
number of rows you want to maximize the
number of rows you want to join so you
may want to use multi sets another case
is let's say you have different
representation of the same additives and
you want to join one of these so you
could do an ad resolution to pre-process
assets so that you can join tables on
the entities we haven't really think
about how to deal with numerical data
because the joint semantics right now
such as equal join doesn't really work
for numerical data with decimal points
especially and we all haven't considered
using embeddings to represent the sets
of data values so that we can join
tables in a semantic space
a different Avenue is to further enhance
the joint was the search indexes so we
can build extension to DBMS we can
consider the case of distributed indexes
and we can also further improve the
performance we can actually talk a
little bit about that offline if you're
interested last but not the least we can
have many different interesting
applications of join portable search the
obvious ones lies in say ml and VI
systems where you can automatically
introduce new features or new attributes
for you and analysis and to other
applications that I have thought about
is the first one is open data so it
citizen data science the idea is we have
so many open data as been published on
the web as we have seen there 100
thousands of tables that would just for
tabular data how do we make a tool that
allow journalists or inspire the
citizens voters to understand public
policy or their implications with
evidence right we don't really have a
very good tools for them we have some
data portals such as data table but is
extremely hard to find data in them or
relevant data sets so we could apply
Jonah portable search to further enhance
those data catalogues for example
another application that we haven't
considered is data marketplace so you
have lots of people selling the data
yeah lots of people would try to buy
data but how am I gonna know that you
are table what your data is valuable to
me right so we may need a third party to
verify that
so you think Joan about table search you
could kind of bridge this to this gap
you can find tables that can actually
join with your table give you some level
of confidence that the data
would be valuable before you pay the
money so that concludes my talk it's a
bit early I'm welcome any questions you
use containment index containment values
between the two joint columns so in that
case I assume I think you assume the
semantic consistency between these two
columns yes
so yeah if that's the case then you can
of course do that so I'm just wondering
if if that's not the case what happens
so for example there are two columns in
two tables they have similar string
values but they are referred to
different stuff so in that case I am
curious about if containment in index is
useful anymore or what's happening after
I think that case was more interesting
is what's after the top right yeah
that's a very good question so I have
three different ideas the first one is
as you mentioned how do we handle the
case when there are two different cases
one is you do the joint but you you join
things that doesn't make sense for
example you join age with ID it doesn't
make any sense so we need to be able to
filter out those candidates so we could
apply some semantic annotation on the
columns so if the the meaning of the
columns are so different then maybe we
should filter them out that's one thing
the other thing is what if there are two
are two table that's supposed to be
joined but because they don't agree
syntactic lis right then we can perhaps
use entity resolution or an grams to to
help them you know increase this type of
recall problem the other question that
you have how how would what happen after
the joy or what happened after you find
those joinable candidates
yes the work that I did does not really
consider the semantic meaning of doing
those choice so we rank the result based
on the join ability and let the user to
decide on say whether this candidate is
meaningful so if I think there's a lot
of work that can be done for that as
well
I think the Carly can be some metrics I
mean after the joint that helps you
determine if there's a good job yeah
yeah thanks there's been work done on
foreign key predictions thank you during
the ones to empty joint but then many
other signals beyond just the
containment may be necessary
if you may need to understand table
names column names and I am Signum
already got that right so that many
prior work that has done yes I mean the
way I see it is that you are having an
efficient way to compute containment on
others a measure that could be used in
such algorithms
yeah so it's like toga no so you can
actually use those at a technique to to
improve that because there are a
precision of the results yeah does your
first work does it
multi-column yeah that's that's one of
the future work that I haven't put it on
yes we are looking at the problem of say
you have very strong signals if you have
multi columns match right and you can
improve the joint accuracy as well so
yeah there definitely are very
interesting Avenue but I think this type
of algorithm would would be using the
single column search as building blocks
so what kind of pre post process and
your on the results of single column
such candidates
need to handle my people yeah yeah
because the mismatch right because we
consider a column with a SAP but now we
break up their role correspondence right
so then there's the search based
attached a bigger that way obvious
question is what do you do with there if
there are two columns that are very
similar in the values but you don't
necessarily have exact matches so in a
way you also join paper already goes in
this direction but it doesn't have to be
the definition of other joint so if I
were to wanted to extend your work to
find two columns which have very similar
but not identical values and again feel
free to use any similarity dimension on
the values themselves can you talk a
little bit about how ever do that there
we could first of all use penguins to
break the values into we don't
necessarily need to fix size and gram we
could use n grams that appears very
rarely that could provide very strong
signals for possible joint and we can
also use there's some previous work in
detecting a regular expression given a
column so we could use regular
expression to tokenize the values into
possible compositions of different parts
and then apply the set similarity search
technique on top of that as well yeah so
yeah
so you talked early about having a very
large corpus of tables and I seen with
that number of tables you must be
crawling the web or somewheres pulling
obviously a lot of these tables are
junky you know they're dirty they're
neutrally inconsistent and so I go up
you know and I go up and I use your
system to find potential joins but then
what I mean
it's it's there maybe how do i how do i
distinguish which joins are actually
going to be producing useful answers or
not do I have to go through a whole
cleaning phase before I ever apply any
of your techniques to a database of a
couple hundred thousand tables that
doesn't seem like it's been working yeah
so yeah I think the for a real world
application of a joinable table search
system we would really need to build out
the refinement phase so given all the
candidates that could be joined we need
to use a lot more signal just beyond
simply containment to understand which
table should rank higher than the other
one so I think it's similar to like a
search engine you you have inverted
indexes to retrieve the candidates a
couple thousand of them and use page
rank algorithms or some similarity
measure to find the results that should
be more bearable according to the query
yeah yes that's definitely - so it's not
that easy because the search engine
handles stuff that people always search
Barack Obama or presidents of the United
States everybody search for that but
when it comes to this domestic search
problem the long tails have users may
have different requirements and they may
not always be the same so yeah it's a
very challenging problem of course
because different analysts may we wants
different type of tables how do you come
up with consists of relevance measure
that works for both that could be very
challenging yeah see either either
you're working with a small
this in which case you have schema you
can do all kinds of even even the N
squared problem analysis of pairwise
table
it's tractable you know as long as the
number of tables doesn't grow too large
and when it grows very large then you
must be working on a very dirty corpus
in which case it seems like the problem
you just described of being able to
understand the quality of the answer and
sorting through which ones are useful or
not is an absolutely essential
ingredient to make this whole thing of
any practical value yeah yeah so I'm
working on it work on it Microsoft I
don't know if you guys are interested as
for example as a user of the system how
I interpret containment threshold like
probably accept it if I don't know
anything about databases what values
should I put there right yeah you can
use cupcake I mean the other case is if
I mean it depends on requirement it
right if you simply kind of casually
browse then I would say top case good
but if you have specific requirement
let's say you really want to cover all
the tuples in your in your table you
don't want any no values you don't want
to do laughs outer join you know in that
case then perhaps you see no strict
containment so I'll show we good oh oh
you understand it forgot for example us
somehow how does it translate I think
it's relevant to your relevance of the
results right right so think about a
foreign key key join case that's
probably the most common use case you
have a query table which has a foreign
key and you want to find a table that
actually use this as a key right in that
case you can say well for all the
different foreign keys I have in my
table how much of it has been covered by
the creek items so that's you say
whether it's a strong indication yeah
it's a boring Kiki relationship or it's
very weak it's not a complete coverage
so if you got a complete coverage then
you can actually join table together
perfectly that's more of a relevance
measure for you for this case and
depends on the use cases of course that
the one that you saw in the demo
neither the query column or the column
that used for join our keys right like
when why join for company names with the
contribution table the contribution
table the key is the ID of the
contribution so we actually how to do an
aggregate over the over the company
names so the really I mean the reason
why we use sets semantics because it's
able to handle that case but if we only
consider number of roles which is
probably more understandable for the
user perspective it may not work as well
because imagine you have end-to-end join
of the same value then it's just gonna
artificially inflate the relevant score
right I hope I don't know hope I answer
your question
so the oxygen summary that I need to
make more clear here the I don't think
people a lot of them are using house and
somebody does we know they're using it
because I also have a different library
in colon that has people using it and
the people are telling me you should add
a license to it otherwise
in use so I'm sure there are people
using it but not as popular as me haha
Sh
so the data sketch library is extremely
popular because at one point somebody
published opening a course I think
online course that talks about data
sketches and uses my library there's a
course material yeah yeah so that's it's
very interesting because a lot of people
try to say I try to contribute to this
library so I for example they even had a
Redis back-end to store the hostage
index and because they they have so many
documents that need to index and the
memory is not even enough so yeah so
that wasn't very interesting any
question
cool
[Applause]